President Trump has given a new
commission 90 days to come up with ideas
to address the deadliest drug crisis in
American history more than 52,000 people
have died of a drug overdose in 2015
mostly from heroin or other opioids the
acting head of Drug Enforcement
Administration spoke only with CBS this
morning about his plans to help the
White House tackle the epidemic
Tony two couples in Louisville Kentucky
where he got a first-hand look at the
desperate fight to save lives right now
Tony good morning good morning deaths
from opioid overdoses have more than
quadrupled since 1999 and that's made
ambulances like this one very very busy
some of the most severe devastation has
been right here in Kentucky and
paramedics who used to go days without a
single overdose are now lucky if they go
just a few hours
paramedic Mary Taylor rushes to as many
as 25 drug overdoses in a single day do
you think it's peaked I don't know I
mean it couldn't get much worse
but on this day
an overdose came to her Taylor joined a
team trying to revive a young man driven
to this hospital in the back of a green
sedan the patient arrived on conscious
and barely breathing but just minutes
later he walked out on his own hey buddy
come on we talked to you for a second
what just happened what happened was a
rescue paramedic sensing a heroin
overdose gave the man naloxone a drug
that stops the effects of opioids I
don't think we're ever going to arrest
or enforce or prosecute our way out of
most social ills DEA administrator Chuck
Rosenberg blames the epidemics rising
toll on a change in use while deaths
from painkillers have plateaued at about
17,500 a year deaths from substitutes
like heroin and potent synthetic opioids
have surged the 22,500 I gotta tell you
it scares the hell out of me these
things can be lethal believe it or not
to the touch in another era the DEA
would have responded with force alone
but in late 2015 Rosenberg launched the
360 degree strategy that blends
traditional police work with public
education changing behavior is tough but
we have to keep Adam we have to talk to
middle and high school kids and we just
have to be relentless about it
Louisville is one of the program's pilot
cities it really affects all parts of
the city all socioeconomic classes all
races Jim Scott is the agent in charge
of the DA's Louisville office have you
seen a reduction in overdoses since the
program began
no we haven't no the numbers have
actually increased in a single four-day
stretch in February 151 overdoses rocked
the city it hurts
yes it hurts because they're not just
spikes they're people near the end of
another day in Louisville Mary Taylor
would welcome relief but she's guarded
about President Trump's chances of
providing him good luck we're all
looking for a way to do it but
I think it's gonna happen now the DEA
believes it has slowed the opioid crisis
if not stopped it
president Trump meanwhile has repeatedly
promised to do even more but so far his
administration is short on specifics and
critics fear that this new Commission to
study the problem is just more talk Alex
Tony thanks that is a staggering number
of deaths from this news and they're
calling it the deadliest drug crisis in
American history drug enforcement
officials health officials have been
talking about this for quite a while now
but I don't think the public really
realized it is a crisis how serious this
is